make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so down in the description of this
video you will find a link to a playlist
basically giving you everything you need
to know to get started with the x-men
right so you're gonna find like a whole
host of explanations the x-men explained
x-factor explained x-force explained the
New Mutants Generation X explained
Cyclops Wolverine Jean Grey apocalypse
mr. sinister you'll find out like a ton
of explanations there's probably about
15 different explanation videos in there
at the moment including things like how
Cyclops has powers work how Wolverines
healing factor works all the different
types of adamantium the origin of
adamantium different things like that we
will add stuff and depending on what it
is that hickman references things like
house of M we can kind of include in
there just because it did not affect
just the x-men it also affected like the
Avengers and all the superheroes across
Marvel different things along those
lines and so because of that hopefully
it'll get you guys prepped but just
remember that playlist is being added to
all the time so it's not static it's not
gonna stay the same these are gonna
change but what I want to do in this
video is kind of start a series of
videos basically kind of creating an
x-men encyclopedia and we're gonna we're
gonna create kind of a an omega-level
mutant power hierarchy if there is such
a thing right because you're just
talking about mutants who were
exceedingly powerful and they're kind of
is you know based on the powers that
they have and so starting this list off
what I've done is is we're gonna go
through here we're gonna arrange them
based on what their powers are which is
to say like how we've seen them
displayed or what the possibility can be
with their powers and that'll get a
little more clear once we're talking
about characters like Pope summers and
Legion and then we'll get into what kind
of a Ranger will go from like
multiversal to universal down to
basically planetary and then strictly
just the human body right like the
ability to manipulate the body or at
least things outside the body but that
are not really considered planetary
Omega level threats so starting with
white Phoenix to the crown Jean Grey now
Hickman did not really list her as his
omega-level mutant in terms of what he's
been doing with house and powers of X
but but the Phoenix force is an
intricate part of gene and you can't
really separate the two and so with the
with the white phoenix of the crown what
we're talking about is a perfect house
for the Phoenix now anybody can be a
white Phoenix to the crown if Marvel
wants them to all they have to do is
come back and just say they're a perfect
host but the way this works is that
anybody can can be a host of the Phoenix
so long as they can with stain the
psychological effect of like cosmic
awareness that it's a saying
knowing everything that's going on in
the universe right now and their bodies
can house that much energy you can
actually channel and control that much
energy they can be a host to the Phoenix
force the difference between a standard
host and the white
Phenix of the crown is the white Phoenix
is based on the notion of a person being
a perfect host of the Phoenix and so
with someone like Jean Grey especially
getting into someone like Emma Frost and
I think Rachel summers this is basically
the notion of individuals who are white
Phoenix like Phoenix of the crown
individuals that's why Marvel keeps it
very very slim is because a person with
this level of power is a multiversal
reality manipulator meaning that power
extends into the multiverse Jean Grey as
the white phoenix of the crown and i
don't care what anybody says is on par
with the Living Tribunal in terms of her
power she can destroy universes she can
create life and she can do pretty much
anything she wants to right I mean the
closest explanation we got or the best
exhalation we got in terms of what what
Jean Grey and anybody who's a white
Phoenix of the crown can do is to fix
what's broken yes I know it's ambiguous
it's Grant Morrison it was a hand wavy
explanation during the story here comes
tomorrow and that was basically yet
right there wasn't really a whole lot of
explanation there it was kind of like
she can do pretty much anything she
wants to and that was basically it now
below her we get Hope Summers and we get
Legion now a lot of people will look at
this and I'll say okay in the face of
characters like Franklin Richards and
mr. M and so on and so forth how can
they be more powerful than them well
this is based on the nature of their
powers hope summers can mimic the powers
of anybody and presumably anything right
there's no upper limit to the powers
that she can manipulate right so she's
very very much and almost identical to
protege from the alternate was at earth
six nine one or whatever it is reality
that exists out there where he copied
the powers of everyone up to the Living
Tribunal and then claimed himself to be
the next one above all now because of
the fact that there's no limit to the
power she can duplicate if somebody like
Franklin Richards ran up on her because
of the fact that her power is passive
meaning she doesn't actually have to do
anything in order for the power to be
activated she would automatically copy
all the abilities of Franklin Richards
and the battle would be a stalemate if
Jim Jasper's ran upon her it would be
the exact same way now we've never seen
her display Universal reality-warping
powers but because she can duplicate the
powers of others there's no reason to
believe that she can't know with Legion
he can basically create an endless
number of personalities and each
personality will have a power the
problem with this is that as a gamble is
a crapshoot he's got hundreds of
personalities thousands of personalities
to be honest and it may be that like you
know three four or five dozen of those
personalities all have the exact same
power they all have telepathy or they
all have telekinesis or something along
those lines the closest we ever really
got to Legion having a personality that
display the ability to manipulate
matter on a relatively large scale was
probably the origamist the ability to
fold reality in on itself and that
really seemed to be about it now we did
get the age of X story and we did get
like the personality that basically
changed reality but it was only on a
universal and in a localized space right
it was I'm sorry on a planetary and
localized space it wasn't as though like
the entire earth and like the entire
universe had been changed during house
of X it was just this one little section
of earth and it was basically being
controlled by Legion himself and so
because of that it gets a little murky
when it comes to these two characters
right I mean there's a lot of ambiguity
there and arguments can be made that
they don't belong this high on the list
I mean those arguments are available and
they can be made but I choose to place
them here because I think it does it
makes things a lot easier now in terms
of Jamie Braddock ah this is the next
one on our list and Jamie is a Universal
reality manipulator
Jamie Braddock's power is not the same
as like Franklin Richards or Jim
Jasper's or anybody like that Jim
Jasper's isn't really considered
omega-level because I guess Hickman
doesn't really consider him to exist and
technically he doesn't right he's been
gone for a long time and really
Hickman's list is based on existing and
currently alive omega-level mutant sin
in Marvel but Jimmy Braddock basically
sees these kind of strings basically I
mean technically it's considered quantum
they're considered called a quantum
strings but essentially he sees these
sort of strings that connect everything
in existence right and all stem from
some particular place but there's
strings that run into humans and they
run into planets and they run into every
single blade of grass and they run into
dogs and cats and bears and and lions
and tigers and oh my I got that out of
order you know they even run into
popeye's chickens so that if he chose to
he can manipulate reality and such a way
to where we can all get that chicken
sandwich because hells bells I'm tired
of going there and seeing the whole line
wrapped around the place and waiting
like four hours in order to get a
chicken sandwich
I'm not waiting four hours to get a
chicken sandwich and I have a hard time
believing it's better than then
chick-fil-a because that spicy chicken
sandwich man at some point okay so back
to the topic at hand in two years people
are gonna be like what the hell is this
guy talking about
not even that like six months ah but
because of the fact that Jimmy Braddock
C strings Jimmy Braddock can kind of tug
on those strings and then basically
create like kind of a cascading effect
right so there's a string that runs from
wherever and to like Franklin Richards
presumably he can tug on that string and
then take Franklin Richards powers away
or age Franklin Richards up to like 90
years old
or something along those lines it's it's
but insofar as kind of pulling on these
strings and just sort of seeing the
effect that happens now for years and
years and years Jimmy Jimmy Braddock's
powers were a bit ambiguous as far as
I'm aware it wasn't until we got in the
house of M and you had Psylocke in
Rachel Summers who were stuck in the
white hot room which is basically where
the Phoenix force resides and Jimmy
Braddock appeared there and was like
here's how my powers work and I think
that's probably the most comprehensive
and the best explanation that we got but
under Jimmy Braddock I would put
Franklin Richards
and then the reason why I put Franklin
here is because Franklin powers as his
younger self are not that well developed
right as more like things just kind of
happen and Franklin doesn't really know
what he's doing case in point during the
story of Dark Reign the Fantastic Four
tie-in Norman Osborn stormed the Baxter
building and said I want all the
technology of the Fantastic Four it was
Franklin and I think like like Ben Grimm
and valaria maybe like one or two other
people but Franklin was wearing this
cowboy hat and he had these little pop
guns and he fired this pop gun ad and
Norman Osborn and a real bullet came out
so like it's the ability to kind of
manipulate you know reality on that
scale but again it's just kind of
accidental so like during the old
Fantastic Four story when he aged
himself up to an adult and basically
looked like Jesus with blond hair then
you get into adult Franklin Richards and
adult Franklin Richards powers are far
more developed
now during Hickman's run on the
Fantastic Four there's something that a
lot of people forget when Franklin
resurrected Galactus from the dead he
basically had the power of his younger
self combined with the power of his
older self so it wasn't his true power
insofar as just him but it's the
combined foul-up power of Franklin from
two generations could resurrect the
laches from the debt now Hickman
basically fixed that right off the bat
after that conflict ended Galactus and
Franklin went to like the edge of went
out into space I think the edge of space
the edge of the universe or something
like that
they were looking at the rift basically
where the universe essentially ended and
then Galactus was like your power is on
par with me we'll live forever we will
be there when the universe ends and when
it went does you and I will merge into a
singular being and we'll be reborn in
the next universe as kind of a Galactus
Franklin Richards hybrid that was
basically the argument so taekman hitmen
established Franklin Richards powers are
on par with Galactus right so that's why
I put him here because he's a universal
reality manipulator effectively if his
powers are on par with Galactus he can
do everything Galactus can do now moving
beyond him and directly under Franklin
we get an ax mister in Absalon Mercator
now Absalon from what we've seen is
basically a planetary and it may be not
even really a planetary but a localized
reality
manipulator insofar as he can manipulate
reality in a localized space we haven't
really seen him do anything beyond that
mostly because the the run of his
character was so short-lived and he
really didn't do a whole lot they
basically just kind of went forward and
and eventually was destroyed by Leachman
or I guess destroyed when leach shut his
powers down and any was taken out but
because of the fact that there's
potential there I mean I guess you could
make an argument he could move beyond
planetary but from what we've seen he's
simply just a planetary reality
manipulator and that's basically about
it not from him we go down into Magneto
now magneto is an electromagnetic matter
manipulator he manipulates the
electromagnetic spectrum the issue with
this and the reason why I put him solo
here is there have been instances like
uncanny x-men number five 21 when he
basically reached out into space several
light-years away from the planet Earth
and then like release Kitty Pryde from
this giant metal bullet or something
like that he was part of the nation act
storyline but like this giant and you
know metal bullet it was existing out
there essentially he uses powers to
control magnetism several light-years
away from Earth which is no small feat
for the most part though his powers are
usually confined to earth now a lot of
that's because he's only ever really on
earth but again sticking with a display
of powers that we've seen we've never
really seen him do anything beyond Earth
we have seen him like bored asteroid M
which orbits earth and then like issue
this giant electromagnetic pulse that
basically shut down all the electronics
on earth itself but we've never seen him
do anything like go out into space and
then move Mars like three feet to the
left we've never really seen him do
anything along those lines now there's
no reason to say that he cannot right
the ability to manipulate not manipulate
metal or a manipulate magnetism
basically means any planet with a
substantial enough amount of metal he
should be able to control the question
is if you were to try to control Mars
with the metal inside of it what all the
metal just rip out of Mars or would it
be able to move Mars because of all the
metal inside because technically he'd be
moving the metal not really the planet
itself he wouldn't really be moving the
dirt the mountains and all that kind of
stuff there's no real grass on on Mars
you know because of the fact that he
can't we don't really seen him do that
we can kind of isolate him to a
planetary omega-level mutant now moving
below him we have Vulcan now Vulcan is a
character who has gone out into space
and he has done things like like face
off against other people but the reason
why I put Vulcan below magneto is
because Vulcan can manipulate energy but
we've never actually seen him manipulate
all forms of energy in a way that makes
him like this colossal threat that's
more substantial than magneto Vulcan has
done things like Cyclops ships is optic
beam
and the Vulcan makes the beam go around
him and then back to Cyclops again
things along those lines now if we go
with potential in terms of the ability
to manipulate all forms of energy and
what he can do with that well then he's
way up there on the list but in terms of
what we've seen displayed in Marvel
Comics and what we know we can't really
put him that high because we haven't
seen anything to indicate that he is
that high up on the on the spectrum on
the hierarchy of omega-level mutant from
there you go into storm now storm an
Iceman or kind of two sides of the same
coin but I would technically put storm
more powerful than Iceman the reason why
is storm manipulates all Maul form of
weather phenomena where I shouldn't
create storms and train hurricanes I
mean she has a really bad day like if
she can't get her hands on a chicken
sandwich and Popeye she'll probably get
pissed off and like okay she's like the
world screwed now typhoons and tornados
and all kinds of crazy things like I'm
basically gonna do the world unless I
get a chicken sandwich but nonetheless
she can manipulate a whole like the
entire weather phenomena of Earth now
it's not just confined to earth it's
also any planet that she goes to but the
issue is she's a planetary elemental
manipulator right so if forest hammer
what a fracture like what a break for
example and like the cosmic storm that
rages inside were to escape and get out
there it'd be cool to see storm control
it but we've never seen her do that
right we can see her go from one planet
to the next and manipulate the weather
on that planet but you can't really
manipulate like cosmic storms or
anything along those lines we've never
seen her do that maybe she can but we've
just never seen her do that before him
so below her we go into Iceman now
Iceman is a little finicky here and it's
a little weird because technically
Iceman is manipulating matter the issue
is that he's only able to sit or at
least it seems like he's only able to
manipulate it in one way cold
is simply the absence of heat right heat
is just matter moving at a really really
fast pace right like atoms just moving
really really really really fast and
essentially creating friction more or
less renomii that's why they say in
chemistry if you want to combine two
elements put them in a beaker and add
heat what do you have Iceman what he's
doing is slowing down the movement of
matter to the point where there isn't
any heat being generated by the movement
of matter and in turn we have cold now
the fact that he can do that is cool but
he's his powers are not on the same
level as storm technically he could
reach on to the core of Earth and like
slow down the movement of the Earth's
core but we've never seen him do that
the only real explanation he got that
was even him being omega-level came from
Emma Frost when she took over his body
but it wasn't really her doing anything
he was her just realizing he was on mega
level because of what it was that he
could do we just haven't really seen the
full height of his power now moving
below him we've got standard Jean Grey
with telepathy now this is probably
gonna be a pretty debatable point among
fans but in all honesty breeding the
x-men as long as I have I'm pretty sure
I'm right here Jean Grey's telepathy is
powerful and she is a very very capable
character the issue is that it's
telepathy so unless you can somehow
control the minds of all beings in the
universe without using the mind stone
she's a planetary threat and that's
basically about it with her telepathy
she's just not that high up there
whether telekinesis she's even weaker or
whether telepathy she hasn't really
compared to like Franklin Richards or
Jimmy Braddock or Hope Summers ability
to duplicate any level of power or
something like that or Magneto's ability
to immediately the entire
electromagnetic spectrum and destroy the
world which isn't really rank high
enough to compete with that in terms of
her telepathy
ah going into Clinton choir he's the
same way no technically quit in choirs a
bit of a cheat sheet and the reason why
is because Quentin used a drug called
kick in order to amplify his powers and
so technically he is an omega-level
mutant but really because he cheated
right I mean you sweep the leg oh you
guys ever saw a karate kid but that was
a great movie back in the day
sweep the knee it was a pretty cool
moment but nonetheless Quinton choir is
an omega-level telepathy is powerful but
it's telepathy the ability to read and
control the minds of others not a whole
lot to really discuss here Exodus
Bennett Boop Harry he is the exact same
way right he's a French guy that has
really high levels of telepathy and
that's basically it now if we were
talking about telekinetic svet changes
the game in its entirety because the
ability to basically manipulate matter
with your mind move objects and
different things like that you can
basically reach down onto the atomic
level but an omega-level mutant with no
definitive upper limit to their power
who up to this point has only really
moved rocks there's no reason to believe
they can't move matter on the atomic
level and then start changing it around
and turning into something else but
we're talking about telepathy there's
pretty straightforward here then you get
down into a lick sir biological
manipulation right it's confined to the
body to it to his body
the bodies of others planetary to a
degree and that's basically about it I
know it seems kind of hand wavy but I
would get sidered him the weakest of the
omega-level mutant that are on our list
now this is what we start getting into
some of the carriages not all of them
but some of the characters that hickman
does not list we into characters like
the marquee of death the marquee of
death I would rank right next to the
white Phoenix with a crown you're
talking about a guy who wiped out an
entire universe by waving his hand it's
an extreme amount of power is absolutely
absurd he's been dead for quite some
time and Hitman does not have him listed
well the marquee of dead
Derwin when he was alive during his
prime was a force to be reckoned with
then you go into Matthew Molloy directly
below below the marquee of death
now put Matthew Malloy here just because
of the fact that he didn't really do
anything that seemed to rival the power
of the marquee of death in terms of like
you know destroying universes things
like that but he does have one feet
under his belt and that's the ability to
resurrect himself from the dead that's a
pretty huge feat to pull off for for any
being out there who's that powerful and
if we chose to use that as a singular
reason for why he's so powerful we could
technically put him above the marquee of
death because of the fact that the
marquee of death couldn't resurrect
himself from the dead but but Matthew
Malloy can't but we never saw Matthew
Malloy destroy universe I never saw
Matthew Malloy like like trick the
entirety of the Fantastic Four Doctor
Doom in the superhero community into
believing they defeated him we didn't
really saw anything like that like
manipulating this reality on such a
scale we never saw anything along those
lines so we can basically you know based
on the powers that we've seen we could
either make them equal or we can put him
below possibly on top depending on what
case you want to make below Matthew
Malloy I've got Jim Jasper's and Jim
Jasper's had a really really cool
display of reality manipulation but it
was not on a universal scale it was in a
localized space that's kind of the
downside there is that when he was
fighting Captain Britain back in the day
he was just changing reality around
Captain Britain right it was snapping
his fingers and Captain Britain was like
a little kid and schoolboys close and
then it was just kind of crazy in terms
of the power that we saw displayed but
because of that it only really seemed to
be on a localized space here and so
moving under that then you go in and
they gray Nick raids an omega-level
mutant it's really cool he's got really
high levels of celebrity really high
levels of telekinesis we've only ever
seen him use his powers on a planetary
scale
Gabriel Shepard the exact same way the
ability to stop time things along those
lines we've only ever seen him as a
planetary threat it's interesting here
because I think what we actually forgot
on our hickman list was Proteus Proteus
ability to manipulate reality in a
localized space within like I think a 50
or 100 foot range or something like that
it's small honestly I would probably put
him on me because he can manipulate
reality on that on that level I would
probably put him below mr. in but above
magneto just because of where his horror
ranks but again the funny thing about
this is that if you really really really
want to get super nuanced you can create
arguments for restructuring this entire
list right I mean I imagine the comments
will be rife with debate and rife with
you Rob you're wrong and that kind of
thing that's fun but going on what we've
seen we can kind of lead these
characters the way they are but you
could remove Legion put him somewhere
else because we've never actually seen
him display an insane amount of power up
but the ability is there you could
change
list up and you can maximize all
possible positions that all these
characters could be in in any particular
order right I mean it's kind of the
nature of omega-level mutant so the
nature of powers is that we're we're
organizing them as best we can but the
argument may be here that there really
is no definitive order to and to
omega-level characters outside of those
who you know going from universal to
planetary to localized and then into you
know the simple manipulation of the
body's atomic structure and that's
basically it
right because technically the definition
of an omega-level mutant is there is no
no definitive upper limit to their
powers they simply just haven't reached
the higher levels yet that really kind
of seems to be the argument and the
debate or at least the position that
that Marvel's going with other moments
so let's be said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come as explained to make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]